[Music]
a new program at unlv is addressing a
critical health care shortage in our
valley there are just 1200 occupational
therapists across our state heather
mills explained how this hands-on
program is preparing the next generation
of healthcare heroes
occupational therapy isn't a
one-size-fits-all approach it's about
mental physical and emotional well-being
and as these students are finding out
the best way to learn is through touch
from the outside a normal house but
inside a living lab full of eager
students in unlv's occupational therapy
doctoral program i feel like in a lot of
communities not a lot of people know
what ot is gina jitt didn't when she was
taking care of her agent grandmother
that's what compelled her to pursue this
field i really thought that she could
have really benefited from ot as she was
aging here it's a hands-on approach the
practical side of education physical
kinds of rehabilitation cognitive
emotional
all of those we're a very holistic
profession
and so we're looking at all aspects of
the human being dr shima krishna geary
says it's about treating the patient and
the patient's family from infants to
elderly to get you back to a very
meaningful productive life whether that
means learning certain skills for the
first time we usually work with
like babies on this balance beam to
practice core strength and footing or
relearning breaking with your left foot
that first time life changes mean
adaptation there's a lot of like
just at home modifications that you
could do with people to keep the home
safe something jitt and her classmates
are learning hands on the therapy is
about patients reclaiming their lives
and that even includes the many who are
still suffering long-haul or covet
symptoms heather mills 8 news now